un titre sans équivoque et un constat
sans ambiguïté des budget sabré des
intermittents fragiliser un patrimoine
abandonné
françois de mazières et olivier le naire
respectivement aux hommes politiques de
droite et journaliste de gauche partage
dans ce nouvel ouvrage la même position
sur le monde culturel français un sujet
et trans partisan est une priorité
nationale pour les deux auteurs on pense
tous les deux que jamais on arrivera à
sortir des ornières dans lesquelles nous
sommes si on n'arrive pas à récupérer la
question culturelle et à la remettre au
centre et ça c'est un combat qui est de
droite de gauche de tout ce qu'on voudra
et c'est d'abord un combat pas des
politiques mais des citoyens réveillez
le monde culturel à quelques semaines de
l'élection présidentielle françois de
mazières décline ainsi dix propositions
le député maire de versailles
historiquement engagé sur la thématique
culturelle lui le créateur du festival
mois molière un événement une cité qui
fêtera cette année ses 21 ans il faut
être fier d'un héritage qui est le nôtre
la france est une ville d'un pays de
culture la france réputation
internationale ans de m eh bien il faut
l'entretenir et c'est vrai dire ça y est
c'est pas si vous voulez ce que j'ai
fait
qui est à mettre en avant c'est que
versailles incarne aux yeux du monde la
culture française et donc on va
aujourd'hui avec mon équipe municipale
j'ai une mission j'ai un devoir c'est
d'essayer de faire encore rayonner la
culture à versailles le grand gâchis
culturel sort en librairie ce mercredi
22 février aux éditions albin michel